今日は外れ社長です皆さん磁石機械ソロけど僕も磁石で重力を無視した部屋を作ろうと
思ってるんで床を全部 n 極にして自分も n 極で猛反発しあって浮いちゃう
みたいなそういうねちょっとムズく空間を作ろうと思ってるんでまぁ今回二施策ですよ
ねそういう兄弟が自作の実験をしようと思ってるんでそこで何かですねちょっと何か
面白いものを見てきたので買ってしまいました
髪の毛
入ってるよなんかこれの見つけましたこれだけ見てはわかりづらいと思うんだけど
磁石が入っていいでしょ
ブーブーいいっ
うわあああああああああこれですっごい面白いと思ったよね10個かありましたこれさ
せてくれないか無限のちっ可能性を感じると思うんですよベイマックス見た人なら
わかると思うんですけどもあの米マックの主人公の浩介あいつはね
天才ではジェットみたいな音なんかロボットをつくって自由自在になく身体を支えれる
みたいな僕もちょっと公式を見習ってねその大量の細い子車
こう使ってなんかいろいろできるんじゃねーかと思いましてねなんかやってみますまあ
このれわーこういったすぎるぞ210610個の磁石ボールがあるんでそれで今日は
この
大量のジャブを使ってどんなことができるのかっていうのはいろいろ考えて皆さんに
教えていいできるレベル0と思いますでいきましょう
ん
ピアスいてどうあピアース the champ 月になってる幌
ん失くした編だけ者なくしたかった
パンッ
管理すごい数の自由が妻の事故になってもこの大き自席であれば
ん
簡単に食べます了花とかで大変ですね押し何かの不慮の事故で打っ一家うボス何かの
事故で歯の両方の鼻の穴2着が詰まってしまった場合普通に撮れますね
finger to ねっ不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
マーケットチャッ草の量の磁石が花火詰まる事故が起きてもこの強力な磁力で
ん
何ドラゴンとか寝起きくれない方金いけない規模しないなぁ微妙っぽいよねほらツって
ありますかノーズで強力だと思います何か作れちゃ作れますね潮流とかこれも暇だな
ねえ族は鉄弾で鎖骨ですよ
コラーッおいを覆った
ああ
おおーー
特に面白くありませんほんといろんな楽しみ方ができますね
じゃあ次行ってみましょうポンッ
ん
結構きちゃっててくれこんなもんかな悪いスレあいつだけでこんな感じですね名の通り
も作れます
はいというちょっと仲良く関連したので実際に撮ってみましょう
しっかり ge 8で止め大丈夫だと思いますいやー
ana
あっはいと言って皆さんいかがだったでしょうかんがじ砂丘がたくさんあってもね
思ってできることですか思ってるできることは少なかったですでジャックっていうかね
力がなくても動くんだよね未来を感じますね楽しんでぜひ皆様行ってみてください
じゃあ入っちゃっ
ん